yeah let me show you this article we got
this is a conversation that occurred
between rep adam kinzinger who hates
trump and hates the maga movement to
wolf blitzer he said that there was a
very real possibility of civil war i'll
just jump down to the powering of the
quote
he said i never would say that we would
ever have ended up in that position but
now i believe it's a real possibility
that we have to be wide-eyed as we walk
into it so we don't have that happen
again
he appeared to mock their health blah
blah talking about trump
wolff blitzer said you it was it was
like you're you're seriously saying you
fear a civil war is possible and he said
a year ago i would have said no not a
chance but i've come to realize that
when we don't see each other as fellow
americans when we begin to separate into
cultural identities when we begin to
basically give up everything that we
believe so we could be part of a group
and then when you have leaders that come
and abuse that faith faithfulness of
that group to violent ends as we saw in
january 6 we would be naive to think it
is not possible here in my earlier
segment i said he was wrong about the
last part i want to revive last part i
want to revise it adam kenzinger's quote
here is one of the most correct
statements ever made i've ever read in
politics
i'll tell you why
he's correct yeah people are tribalizing
but he goes on to say
when that faithfulness of that group uh
when you have leaders that come and
abuse the faithless of that group to
violent ends as we saw on january 6 we
would be naive to think it's not
possible here now at first i was saying
he's wrong about that because that
manipulation is is it's not driven by it
it's an exaggeration the conflict we're
seeing and i'm going to revise that
what we're seeing is on january 6 a
bunch of democrats and a bunch of unit
uniparty politicians like kinsinger
weaponized a ride at the capitol to use
the power of law enforcement to crush
their political rivals and disqualify
them from holding office he's correct
they are abusing the faithfulness of
their in-group to wield the power of
government against their political
opponents he's wrecked when people start
viewing each other as
the good guys versus the fascists or
whatever
there's nothing you can do about i don't
like the left right paradigm because i
don't think of the leftist villains i
don't want to think ever think of other
people's villains in this game
we'll die if that if we play sometimes
people are villains well yeah people
everyone can be villainous but that
doesn't mean that people are villains
well i mean
we just read a story
about capital police officers dressed as
construction workers breaking into a gop
rep's office i know that there's a
global fascist attempt at a takeover i
understand it's been going on for like a
hundred it's probably going on for a
thousand two thousand years since the
romans slavery is that evil what they
did it's horrible yeah it's devastating
okay okay
human soul now now when the capital
police powers were expanded by the
january 6 committee and they're there
are those people evil fascist militants
okay so so here's my issue i'm
specifically referring to the democrat
you to party politicians who are
manipulating the people to gain power
now what happens in most wars when you
have regular people who don't have
anything to do with the conflict
are pulled up into that conflict and are
sent out as soldiers to go fight and die
the point is the little guy is always
the pawn they're always manipulated by
the powerful elites
right now you have do nothing neocon
republicans you have american you know
um
pro-america uh anti-establishment
figures of varying political backgrounds
and
they say
fascist and all right they would accuse
you of being all right and fascist this
would result in people physically
attacking you or this show getting
swatted because people tried to kill us
twice
isn't that evil
isn't it yeah that was a
if they knew what they were doing yeah
it's attention so when he says that you
have leaders abusing the faithfulness of
their group to violent ends he's right
right oh yeah and so what do you do when
you have my let me ask you ian if if a
zombie horde was coming at you and
threatening you would you be like the
zombies don't know what they're doing
they're not evil
no you'd be like
sorry i mean the point of the game is to
kill the zombies then you kill the
those are zombies it's a fantasy what
i'm saying is when you have a large
political faction two large political
factions and they inherently they have
fundamentally different world views
it doesn't matter who's right or wrong
at that point certainly i think some
people are more right than others and
some people are more guilty than others
the issue is adam kinzinger says a civil
war is is is very possible and you'd be
naive to think otherwise the fact is you
have troy nell saying this did happen to
me i truly believe if civil war is
possible and if you think otherwise
you're deluding yourself it's completely
possible right now we have to be careful
that it doesn't happen but here's my
point to make to you
you say you don't want to you know in
group out group or left and right that
doesn't matter
these people already hate you and they
will never like you most people don't
hate me that you know i mean i don't
really know what everybody says like hey
ian i hate you yes
i don't care about texts on the internet
that
dude so ian you are you're correct that
in your everyday life most people you
encounter who aren't chronically online
aren't going to have any kind of issue
with you however they have already drawn
battle lines and they don't see you as a
human being they see you as
representative of everything evil in the
world because you oppose their ideology
so it doesn't matter if you put them in
the category of evil they view you as
evil and they will do everything they
possibly can to eliminate your rights
you you may be right but we're you're
making assumptions let me let me ask you
something i don't think so would you uh
er you're in a museum and there's the
constitution in that glass
and you're standing in front of it and
then all of a sudden a bunch of people
come in and they say get out of the way
ian we're going to burn that burn that
constitution would you would you say
probably step aside yeah we gotta have
weapons and pitchfork yeah i'm not
giving my life for a piece of paper i
know what the constitution says i have
pictures of it well a lot of people in
this country would be like i will not
step aside well that's then they're
they're worshiping an idol and they
should stop doing that it's not
worshiping again
it's a piece of paper who cares we have
the document we don't need the paper so
so this is kind of my point there are a
lot of people in this country who would
be like this founding document
created the greatest nation on the
planet preserved civil rights granted
civil rights made one of the greatest
economies and
the american dream i will sacrifice
myself to make sure that other people
have that same opportunity that i will
do but i'm not going to not for a piece
of paper for the idea
i mean whether you would agree to
sacrifice yourself or not i think saying
it's just a piece of paper is really
reductionist
it's so much more than the sum of its
parts as i would say
and
also it really represents something so
for example if you have like a signed
photographer or you have a you know a
family heirloomed from a loved one who
has passed away it takes on a meaning
beyond the literal object itself and
that's of course true of the
constitution as well but is that that's
idolization i don't think so no you can
recognize the context of something and
see its value based on that without all
these these rocks and gems
i would smash these two bits dude i
don't care
um but i i think that one of the
problems with with idolizing and idol
worship at its root is that you're
putting something in a category where it
doesn't belong and i don't think the
constitution merely belongs in the
category of piece of paper it's it's
obviously a lot more than that i kind of
see like burning a flag like it's just a
symbol the data is important we need to
preserve the data but the con the
constitution itself is not right or like
a document so uh you're standing in
front of the uh amalgam of u.s history
the last remaining copies of all for it
man
if i if this is my life to preserve the
state yeah
so this is this is probably a better way
to uh to explain it the left wants year
zero right pol pot he wanted to purge
all you know culture uh mao great leap
forward all that stuff cultural
revolution they wanted to purge the all
the traditional stuff this is indicative
of the communists as opposed to the
fascists who are very traditionalists so
you have a faction in this country that
is lying about history 1619 project is
fabricated it makes no sense they say
this country was was created as a
slaveocracy that's an overt lie it's an
outright lie it's just not true and they
say the purpose of this country was that
white people could have slaves it's
literally not true it's not true yeah so
you have
actual history and there's probably a
lot of problems with history let's be
real cause it's written by a you know
it's written by the victims his story
but let's but but you but you would
you would die to preserve the truth
yeah man they would kill to destroy the
truth i know
so what do you do when you are tasked
with preserving the truth and they are
tasked with destroying it i'd be as
subtle as i can until the very moment
and then they're like okay now it's your
chance and to get have the power and
then when they're like
now give me the power back ian i give
him the power back it's the unstoppable
force and the immovable object so this
is how war happens it doesn't matter if
you think they're evil or not what
matters is there are a lot of regular
people who don't pay attention who only
watch cnn who have no idea what you know
and when they see the truckers they're
told they're fascist far right white
supremacists and they say okay
and then they go and vote for
politicians who weaponize law
enforcement to crush political opponents
and then you have whatever this weird
group of people we are which is you know
post liberal libertarian conservative
and we're like the truth is what's what
matters most i think about it almost
every day i mean how do you navigate in
a system where it's basically built with
people that will kill sociopaths that
will kill to preserve power and snub out
that version of history they don't want
to be told but to be an honest
truth-teller how like how do you do that
in this world you got to make people
laugh you got to make sure everybody has
fun while you're doing it and maybe you
can make the villainous authoritarians
realize hey it's it's life's pretty cool
and it's okay if it's not the way you
want it to be
beating him in elections a few times in
a row would help i don't know yeah
political parties do change the results
of that like my long-term thesis about
like what is what does victory look like
in the medium term is something like
what the conservatives in england did to
the labor party in the 80s when margaret
thatcher just beat labor badly like
three times in a row
um and labor went from being like a
pretty hardcore socialist movement to
like the neoliberal tony blair
party because they wanted to win um and
so i think you know the world where
a world where like republicans win like
three or four elections in a row
convincingly and and i think that's
quite possible in a world where the left
keeps doing this stuff they've they've
absolutely the left has found itself i
mean they're they're moving towards
censorship they're moving towards the
stuff because they're losing traction
the generic ballot poll was something
like for the first time it's like plus
four for republicans it hasn't been plus
for republicans in two decades or
something and gallup found a party
affiliation for the first time in like
30 years is now pro-republican right so
if uh so so this is all very doomsday to
be humbly honest however
if in november republicans get a
commanding sweep and then immediately
put a stop to what the democrats are
doing
and shut it all down
then i would actually say i think you
know things are set like the the the
temperature's lowering the the the the
boil is reducing and then um it depends
on how democrats respond to it because
you still have the executive branch you
still have joe biden then we'll see what
happens when donald trump he's running
he's it's no question about it he's
effectively said he's running and all of
his you know former staff well many of
his former staff have publicly stated
he's running even to us
then when he runs
we'll see what happens
because you look at what happened on
january uh 20th 2017 with the rioting in
dc the insurrection you take a look at
what happened in uh what when was it
when the far left was trying to jump the
the fence the white house and set fire
they literally broke the barrier of the
white house in
the summer of 2020 and they set fire to
a guard post they they set fire to a
church 50 uh agents were injured it was
20 20. wow yes that was in 2012
so so what do you think happens if we
get
if we get in november a republican sweep
of congress and then they start passing
bills and laws
the left who's already
completely insane are going to
reignite the whole blm wave of rioting
all that all that insanity is going to
be right there this is the burning of
the saint john's church is what you guys
and that's a dc it's june 2nd 2020. so
what happens then in uh 2024 when it's
like september and donald trump is
winning in all the polls
do you think they'll
learn their lesson and anthony will come
out and be like we're so sorry we did
this to you guys please don't vote for
them or do you think they're going to be
like fascists have won it's time to
revolt well yeah so first of all
obviously i know you're you're being a
little facetious there but they will
never apologize for anything they'll
just move on to the next racket and
they'll start pointing the finger
republicans look at all these horrible
things they've done look at the human
rights abuses trump wants to implement i
think people are going to be smarter
than to look where the people who were
burning the country down
are pointing i can't imagine that people
would support another year of rioting
and burning buildings yeah well and also
i don't so we we've we've discussed this
before and we've we've um compared the
way the left behaves to a child throwing
a temper tantrum and it really can go in
one of two directions when they keep
throwing the tantrum and it doesn't work
they can either double down and keep
doing it or they can grow up and learn
how to behave productively i'm not sure
which direction they're going to take
it's it's going to be
very dependent on the particular left
wing
to shape culture like what i think one
of the you know one good thing that
would come out of a law that sort of
banned social media censorship and
de-platforming is it would just take the
teeth out of all this dumb activism that
seems to juice the most authoritarian
impulses to the left right social media
you know like yes if they if if you
could just get them like if this joe
rogan stuff would be like spotify would
put out instead of that simping like
ridiculous statement that the spotify
ceo put out about how sorry he was if he
just put out a statement that was like
federal law prohibits us from doing
anything like what you guys suggest so
joe rogan's staying on the platform uh
you know take a hike and if that were
that i mean you know take that across
like youtube twitter whatever all those
companies just realized if we do what
the leftists want we'll be in violation
of federal law and yeah yeah you know
like so that would i mean it would do a
lot to decrease the temperature well and
i agree with you i think that that would
decrease the temperature a lot one thing
i said on the show the other day is that
i've known a lot of left-wing people and
i've seen how they behave in groups and
i've also seen how they're willing to
behave one-on-one with me when they have
conversations and they are
far more left-leaning when they are
around other left-wing people what i
like to say is you're honestly not a
leftist until there's two of you when
you're alone having a conversation with
someone who has a different political
perspective than you you're much more
open and willing to hear but as soon as
they get around someone who is
left-leaning they feel the need to
signal that they're the more
left-leaning person that starts with
someone with a weak mind that just
adapts to whoever they're around that's
that's what it is yeah i want to explain
why i think a republican election is
more likely to result in violence and
escalation than de-escalation and you
were mentioning beating them a few times
in a row might be good but you take a
look at the punch-a-nazi thing that
happened
when the left engages in violence the
media celebrates and cheers for it when
the left tore down the security barrier
at the white house and then set fire to
a guard post in a church and trump was
forced into a bunker they made fun of
him mocked him and called him bunker boy
and cheered for it when blm burnt down
causing buildings causing two billion
dollars in insurance damage and that's
the minimum that's that that's the max
payout so that's not even i should say
the minimum that's not even all the
damages and they said your insurance
will cover it when david dorn was shot
in the chest and killed over a tv they
didn't talk about it they didn't care
when they commit acts of violence it's
it's powerful resistance against evil
and fascism
so if if republicans end up winning it
justifies everything they've said maybe
but i mean it depends if we get a little
bit more of a competent administration i
don't know that we will because i mean
i'm not you know impressed i mean
trump's big weakness is his ability to
make the rest of the executive branch do
what he wants or do you know he's just
not good at it right he's not good at
influencing but i don't know you get a
scientist type in there i don't i don't
i just i mean it's just what what
happens in a world where like doj
actually meaningfully enforces the law
and starts imposing serious penalties on
these people like i mean there's there
the reason this stuff happens in my
judgment a big chunk of it it's not
substantially deterred like they're just
not prosecuted
um and i think you you start that's
that's my point like you like you saw
jason charter right that kid who like
punched do you remember that time that
jack got punched or you know pushed
around at that lincoln rally or whatever
that kid got like
three months probation
and that after he also destroyed some
monuments right he was like charged with
destroying monuments a felony that got
pled down to misdemeanor and he only got
three months per day so if
trump ends up getting elected in 2024
and we make it through the next several
years without substantial violence and
escalation and then he purges the
executive branch the department of
justice to replace all these prosecutors
and these federal prosecutors across the
country who didn't prosecute any of this
maybe then we'd see some meaningful
change but that is taught that you what
you're basically saying is he needs to
purge the entirety of the other
political faction i don't know that he
needs to purge the entirety of the other
political faction out of doj but he
definitely needs to like purge the top
ranks needs to like and there needs to
be much more i mean another big problem
is that doj was just swallowed up in an
endless scandal right like i mean the
mueller report and the russia nonsense
like most of trump's first term was just
you know swallowed by distraction rather
than governance when the democrats are
in power
when the left the progressive left the
establishment have power
they use it to justify a mandate from
the people to do all these things
when they're out of power they they
claim the fascists are winning and use
it to justify their acts of violence and
revolt against the system until they get
power back
so i just i look at everything that's
been happening and i there's that you
know quote i think camera i keep
forgetting the guy's name where he says
when i'm weak i ask you for freedom
because it's according to your
principles when i'm strong i deny you
freedom because it's according to mine
that's from dune that's uh that's
herbert herbert frank herbert frank
herbert the author of doom yeah
so if the republicans win in november
certainly i think they'll start taking
action and trying to pass bills biden
will probably veto a good majority of
them
and the left will argue see we were
right the whole time we need antifa and
we need to engage in direct action
they'll call it to stop the fascists
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time